overdose deaths in america hitting a
record high fueled in large part by
highly lethal street fentanyl the number
of americans dying surpassing a hundred
thousand for the first time last year
drug traffickers preying on people as
young as teenagers mixing fentanyl with
other drugs and putting it in fake pills
the cdc says these fentanyl overdoses
were the leading cause of death for
americans between 18 and 45. a majority
of the chemicals in the deadly drug are
produced in china
and come into our country from the
southern border the dea
says it's time to crack down
china's to blame chinese chemical
companies are the largest producer right
now of the precursor chemicals that are
being used to make fentanyl there's a
relationship between these chinese
chemical companies and the criminal
cartels in mexico i think it's important
to talk about the border and i can say
with 100 percent assurance that the
criminal drug cartels in mexico will
stop at nothing to get fentanyl into the
united states
judge go ahead
you know what what she's saying
she could have said four years ago
absolutely there's nothing new in what
she said and the problem is that we've
got a president who is not focused on
this and not focus on the number of
young people who are dying and
everybody's saying it's overdoses and
i'm going to say the obvious that
everybody at this table already
understands and that is that the
precursor to fentanyl and fentanyl is
coming from china through the cartels
they're doing the money laundering this
is in an undeclared war by china against
the united states they are killing young
people who are borrowing pain pills that
are imprinted as though the real pills
but they're they're laced with fentanyl
they are killing us
what do you think the chances are
geraldo when xi jinping or whatever his
name is was on the phone with our
president do you think our president
even mentioned fentanyl in a two and a
half hour conversation he may have me
i've been covering the war on drugs
so-called since uh richard nixon
declared it back in 1971. and i'll i'll
tell you this forget about and not
forget about we don't worry about the
things you can't do something about what
you can do is tell your kid
don't use that drug whatever it says it
is
whether it's meth or cocaine or or hair
whatever it says it is remember prince
it's probably
fentanyl and it's going to kill you it's
going to kill you wait wait wait
fentanyl is killing more than aids car
crashes and guns yes and we lost two
kids at ohio state the other day yeah
and you had the west point graduate
every parent yeah every parent says this
to your children don't don't take
anything don't take any pill that anyone
gives you because you don't know what's
in it no matter what they tell you but
so that's one front of this the other
front is to keep it from getting into
the country and i will say president
trump at least tried with president xi
uh he brought this issue up and they you
know supposedly had some sort of
agreement which obviously fell apart
unfortunately but there was an effort
made at that point um but but the
problem is that you know what exactly
what janine is saying this is a this is
another way to infiltrate this country
the chinese are doing this through drugs
they're doing it through the economy
they're doing it through putting people
in american corporations and
universities they're doing it in taiwan
they're doing it in hong kong buying
farmland exactly so i mean
and this isn't something that we hear
the president talk about in a
comprehensive way and say look we need
to understand this we are up against the
this this aggressor in all of these ways
um we need to take it i feel like a lot
of times you know people from the white
house go on they talk about stuff you're
like
does this really matter yeah does this
really matter why are we talking about
the other stuff that we know matters
right and how about this this is what i
think is especially insidious about this
it's one and done you don't like
necessarily oh i'm doing crack and i got
addicted to crack and you end up dying
you make bad decisions one and done in
things maybe overcounted drugs that are
laced with this and i think this is
china's opium war on us they should be
blaming britain for it but they're
blaming us for it they think they'll
take us down from the inside but it's so
simple it is made in china given to the
cartels brought across the border the
mexican government is scared of the
cartels so let's help him out like mark
esper wrote about and the person says
how do i stop it why don't we bomb them
ourselves maybe you can't do it that way
but we do help other groups other
governments crack down on their
terrorists cartels are terrorists the
mexican government is key the mexican
government's cooperation is so crucial
if you want to control immigration you
need the mexican government to be on
your side yeah but the mexican
government doesn't exist the cartels run
the mexican government and that's the
whole problem we can empower the
government we ca exactly and that's what
donald trump did he empowered the
mexicans with a stay in mexico policy
when before that everyone said mexico
doesn't care well you can make them care
and suddenly they had all of their own
police forces on the mexican side of the
border and one other thing i forgot was
kovid intentionally or unintentionally
yep um killed close to a million
americans this you know
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now